this is looking all promising so fingers
crossed
[Music]
you're saying it's streaming live is it
and yeah that's it
okay sorry about that
perfectly okay well done son yeah
tell me when
we're fine to start please shaman thank
you
uh good evening everybody and welcome to
roger district council's
remote standards committee meeting and
welcome to anyone who is watching this
via our live stream
so if we can turn to the agenda agenda
item number one is apologies for absence
uh no apologies have been received and
in the office are there any
apologies for absence members
um we we have apologies from cancer
stanley
and from um mrs linda walker
thank you sonia agenda item number two
uh substitute members um i understand uh
councillor stu wilson is attending as a
substitute member
on behalf of the green group um
and i believe council newport is
attending on behalf of councillor
standing stanley is that correct
that's correct chairman lovely thank you
gender item number three non-members
attending
so we have yeah we have a step we have
attending chairman
councillor fd councillor mrs mason
council award councillor mrs rowe
councillor whatton and cancer sparing
thank you sonia
moving forward agenda item number four
the minutes of the meeting held on the
11th of september 2019
for those who are present are the
minutes agreed please members
agreed thank you members
um at this point i'd like to refer
members to the final page of the minutes
um these refer to the recommendation to
full council
that the council approved on the 18th of
february
2020. and this reads
that the composition of the member
training working
group be decided and constituted by the
standards committee
starting from the next municipal year
onwards
we are now in that municipal year so
members
i would like to ask would anyone like to
volunteer to sit on the working group
during this municipal year if you could
please show your hands
so if you could raise your blue hand
icon that would be great
thank you very much
so and chairman may i um just
ask a question sorry as i'm substituting
for cancer stanley
yes you may counseling your paul um as
councillor stanley is
not here i'll i will put cancer stanley
forward
for the the member working group and i
hope that
he accepts that um let me just check
with officers if that's um
possible is that correct angela
i mean if uh counselor newport is
putting forward counselor stanley
and if he is chosen to be on the working
group you will be
a member of that working group
thank you so um
correct me if we're wrong here um we
have got councillor mrs gooding has put
herself forward
counsellor mr mike stephtown
councillor mr stuart wilson
councillor mrs june lumley
councillor mrs christie mason
[Applause]
some new you may have to help me if i
don't have to take my glasses off while
i'm reading this
so um i would like to put myself forward
as well for the
um okay
metis we have got
excuses i was indicating to speak
not to put myself forward
did you want to take your hand back down
at this point
council mason the decision that's being
made at the moment so i assume there
would be some debate allowed
um you've got a question would you like
to um say that nominees
um council mrs mason
i can speak now can i thank you um yeah
i i would like to
question this one of the strengths and
the
the working group for the last three
years
so one of the strengths of the working
groups the last three years
has been that it's been compiled of a
member from each group
which led to some robust and um
interesting debates but it's also meant
that there was no political bias on the
working group which i'm sure
bearing in mind it's for member
participation
and member training and learning is
something that we would hope
not to go into it and i think that
before
we ask for volunteers for the committee
the working group committee we should
consider how that committee
is going to be higher
i'm not eligible well actually anyone's
eligible because you don't have to
select from members of this committee
you can select from the whole council
but i'm not putting myself forward
for the working group just to be clear
thank you
thank you councillor mrs mason does
anybody else want to speak on this
yes now i speak i'm not sure if i've
managed to got my hand up on it
thank you very much yes please um uh mr
sheppard
i feel it would be better if it was
non-party organized however you wish to
do that
and as far as the independence we would
take it in terms
that's how it worked before and i must
admit it did seem to work reasonably
well
yes thank you
and yes it's agreed the independent
representatives on the working group
um we have um
just uh counsellor mrs mason we have
had people now put themselves forward
from
the various groups sorry sorry
um sorry chair
um could you raise your hand please
thank you um
so councillor um uh mrs carter you want
to speak
thank you thank you chair and can i just
um
say that i've just joined uh this
committee
and i'd like to have it noted that
obviously i wasn't
at the last minute meeting so i can't
agree your minutes
that's fine thank you very much mrs
councillor mrs carter
so um
so we have um uh seven people put their
names forward
this includes an independent member um
sonja
is it five members that we need for the
um chairman um the the committee can
kind of can agree on the on the
composition of the working group
um it's for the committee to uh to agree
the um you know the size and the
composition
um can can i can can can we please have
clarification of those members that
that are actually volunteering is it
uh councillor stanley council mrs
gooding
councillor steptoe councillor wilson
councillor mrs lumley and councillor mrs
mcpherson
is that is that all the members are
there are there no others that
uh that are wanting to uh put themselves
forward i'm trying to work out how many
that is one two
that's um that that's that's six members
isn't it
it did you have um that plus says
plus the independent member mr mr
shadbard
yep did you have counsellor mr steptoe
on your list and councillor mrs gooding
i did yes so that's that's six six
district numbers
plus uh mr shadbolt
thank you sonia so can you take us
through the process
please so if um
so if if members um if i think we
we should formally um have a roll call
of names uh chairman
to agree to the working group being
comprised of
councillor stanley councillor mrs
gooding councillor steptoe
councillor wilson councillor mrs lumley
council mrs mcpherson
and mr shadbolt
thank you sonya okay so um
so we um we need we would need to go
into a roll call of names so that we can
have everyone's agreement
to the uh composition and the names
there that i've just read out to the
chairman
yep is everybody clear how that works
would you like to explain it please
sonia
for members who don't usually go through
this process
um so what uh what we need to do is i
will um i will read out the uh
i will read out um your your names and
you will need to indicate if you want
a recorded vote and whether you're
voting for
or against the uh the the the
composition and the membership of the
working group
or whether or not you wish to abstain
from voting okay
so um if i start with uh counselling mrs
carter please
thank you yes a recorded vote and agree
thank you uh cancer mrs gooding
not a recorded vote and i agree thank
you
councillor lucas gayle no
to a recorded vote and agree
thank you councillor mrs lumley
no to a recorded vote and agree
cancer mrs mcpherson no to a recorded
vote and agree
councillor uh cancer newport sorry
sorry i didn't know uh no recorded vote
and
four could you just record my name in
the minutes please certainly
cancer steptoe no recorded vote and
agree
and cancer wilson
no recorded vote and agree
thank you
chairman that was unanimous thank you
very much
okay moved on to agenda item number five
are there any declarations of interest
please
there are none moving on
a gender item number six
this is the local investigations and
determinations
from october to 2019 to march
2020 and then april 2020
to september 2020. um
angela laura our monitoring officer will
present her report
if there are any questions on this item
please ask angela to respond to those
thank you chairman yes this is um the
usual report that comes to standards
committee
uh providing members with the summary of
the complaints and queries received in
relation to members behavior under the
code of conduct
in this report we have got two sets of
summaries
uh one dating from october 2019 to march
2020 and then april
2020 to september 2020
that is because due to the pandemic uh
the standards committee
was cancelled in march a copy of the
table and of the summary is appended to
this report
uh chairman i'm asking members to uh
note the summary of complaints
received for that period of october 2019
to march 2020
and april 2020 to september 2020. thank
you
thank you angela uh councillor mr
newport
thank you chad have your hand raised
yeah thank you
thank you chairman if i may um ask
angela
laura via yourself um on
um page 6.1 uh 2.5
uh the monitoring officer has stated
there's no prescribed time limit for
investigation of complaints
and i would like to know if that's
applicable to
a complaint made um
complain actually if i just refer on 6.6
sc0076
if if a member
discloses uh breaches of council's
um exempt um private and confidential
material
and then subsequently is
no longer a counsellor as because the
time limit has
gone over into an election period how is
how is that um handled by
the council's um standards process
is it taken into a legal matter or
what would happen because i understand
that to be a very serious offense
thank you chairman um under the
legislation unfortunately if
if um the councillor that is being
complained of it
no longer is a counselor then there's
not much the council can do that the
complaint
actually ceases there um and it's not
really much the council can do in
in terms of timing of the complaints
received and how long the investigation
takes um i do understand uh council
newport's
point about the serious defense but
again
in accordance with national justice all
these complaints must be investigated
thoroughly
does that answer your question council
newport
chairman can i just um follow that that
up with uh
thank you um so if a counselor
has a number of private and confidential
documents and then subsequently is no
longer a counsellor and
reveals the content of that how would
that be dealt with
it really is down to the count if
they're no longer a counsellor for
whatever reason whether they resign
whether they're deselected whether
they're not elected
really is down to the council to hand
over all um
uh council um equipment papers and stuff
like if uh counselors were issued with
laptops we wouldn't expect you to keep
those laptops
um if there's papers that are private
and confidential then we
would expect that's to do with council
business then we would expect
that to be returned if you receive
private and confidential information in
your capacity
as a accounts are dealing with your own
constituents and you collected that data
yourself then that's a matter for you to
deal with and
a matter for you as you will be the data
controller for that
for that information not the council
thank you thank you
uh councillor mrs carlton you have a
question
yes thank you chair angela i'm i wonder
if i could just ask you um
on two of the complaints it's saying
that there is an apology for the next
public meeting
uh that particular person has to make an
apology um
how are you monitoring that because
obviously the next public meeting is
probably not going to be happening for
quite a while so do you keep a check on
this please
um with regards if it's a
parish council then obviously we have no
control over when their public meetings
will be but we do liaise with the clerk
and we do uh notify the clerk of my
decision with regards to that
unfortunately under legislation if the
council refuses to apologize though
again there is not much recourse for
for for me to however the decision that
is published on the
um council website will have mentioned
that there has been a breach and an
apology
is expected thank you
thank you uh councillor mrs carter says
answer your question
yes thank you lovely uh councillor mr
wilson you've got a question
uh thank you chairman yeah it's really
just to follow up council newport's
point
and the monitoring officer's answer um
as i understand it
that
if you release this information whether
you're a counselor or not
have you actually committed a criminal
offense is it a statutory offence
for an example would be someone who has
government central government
information they may leave the
government
employment but if they link that
information they're still covered by the
official secret sect
so irrespective of whether we can do
something as a standards committee or
you as a monitoring officer
have they actually committed a statutory
offence
chairman the information we usually deal
with doesn't really fall under the
official secrets
act or really any national security um
if if there is um
a disclosure then um
and it is a criminal offence um then yes
that will be dealt with by
other enforcement agencies um the only
criminal offence under the code of
conduct is
is really if there's a a fraud that the
councillor has um um has
acted upon but really all the offences
are civil
under the code of conduct
thank you uh councillor wilson does that
answer your question
well sort of but it raises another
question which is what what comeback is
there on someone
in effect what you're saying is that
anyone can release this information
and it'll go through um civil call which
will probably take forever so actually
there's
almost no sanction is that the case
unfortunately chairman um that is a
weakness of the
uh legislation there is almost no
sanction however it will depend
upon each case and and the facts of each
case as to how serious that disclosure
is
um and and the council will then decide
what appropriation to take
um from that point onwards
thank you uh councillor uh mr mike
stepton
um two points if i may
chairman um one picking up on the point
that council carter raised
uh if the councillor um
refuses to give an apology can i ask the
monitoring officer can
even if it is a parish councillor can
that uh councillor be requested to have
training
instead of that's my first question bill
that first
yes uh chairman um with regards to
sanctions um
you can also apology but they can be
recommendations for training
um and other appropriate recommendations
depending on what the
uh breach has been um you can even
include taking away
the members equipment if it's necessary
sorry i may have perhaps i didn't make
myself clear if
as it's a parish member in this
particular instance we're talking about
if that parish member doesn't agree to
give an apology a public apology
can you then go back and recommend that
parish councillor has
further training i can recommend
that there is further training however
again there's no
there's nothing within my power to force
that member to have
um additional training however this is
where we have to work with the clerks
and the class would have to
and the chairmans of those parishes and
persuade that member to do so
my second point chairman uh picking up
on councillor wilson's uh point with
uh private confidential if um
a member ceases to be a member but he's
been party to
uh commercially sensitive information
particularly over contracts
and relief addiction to uh the
competitors
within the contract would how would that
be dealt with
it would depend on what the
commercial um agreement is
sometimes there may have been some
undertakings um
given um by the council that and and
their members would have had to
um declare that they will not on uh
would not release that information
and once that declaration is made should
anything happen to that information and
it is released
then any legal action that could be
taken against the council and that
ex-member
then that ex-member would not be
protected you would not be
offering protection against that for
that member so potentially there still
could be litigation against that
particular myth really
i'm our ex-member we should say yes
thank you
thank you and uh councillor mrs cohen
no it it's am i unrooted can you hear me
yes [ __ ]
counselor mrs cohen
yeah i believe that nelk have drafted a
new code of conduct
although i don't know how far it's gone
but it does contain
more sanctions and penalties than a
currently
in existence just to comment really that
that is in the pipeline
chairman just in response to that the
lga the local government association
has drafted a new model code of conduct
and that
was recently um subject to consultation
for all members and all officers that
consultation is closed and currently the
council and par
is current sorry currently the council
is waiting on the results of that
consultation before we can take anything
forward
uh thank you um i've got a question
um it's um again on page six point six
um item four um sc sc0076
um this appears to me to be quite a
serious breach
now we're not privy to the information
behind
this um but attending
a code of conduct training and then no
further action
was that the sole sanction
because what will deter somebody from
possibly doing this again are there
further sanctions
chairman i believe in this case what
happened was that the member it was
a human error that it was released and
he
as soon as it was made
as soon as he was made aware by the
managing director
um swift action was taken to remove
uh that information and he he did
apologize
to the council so can i follow up then
um
obviously it wasn't included in this
that it was
um done accidentally um should it have
been
um something shared with intent to share
it
even though it shouldn't be what would
be the sanction then
sorry could you repeat that again if
confidential information is shared
in with intent
what would the sanction be again
chairman it depends on each case and the
facts of each case um and and how it
happened that's why investigations are
very important
because um depending on on what happened
and the mindset behind it
that that can help determine what
sanctions are taken at the end
thank you um are there any more
questions i can see no more
hands raised
in which case um if we can
go to the bottom of page 6.1 there's one
recommendation
that the summary of complaints and
determinations for the period october
2019 to march 2020
and april 2020 to september 2020
be noted is that noted members
noted thank you very much
okay moving on um
agenda item number seven report to this
uh
report of the standards working group
and firstly may i thank the chairman of
the working group councillor mrs mason
and ask her to introduce the report of
the working group
thank you thank you madam chairman
um i would like to thank
all the members of the member learning
and development working group
for all the hard work that they had
input since 2017
when this group was formed whilst all
members contributed in a positive and
constructive manner
the continuity provided by councillors
mrs hoy
councillor stanley and councillor mrs
weston
and mr shadbolt as the independent
person
deserves special thanks i would also
like to place on record the valuable
assistance provided by our
officer michelle powell whose extensive
knowledge greatly assisted the group
the member learning and development
group have been successful in covering
the legal requirements of training
and members needs within a fixed budget
the group have achieved a great
deal of improvements in the three years
of programs that they have
produced some of which are
member and officer suggestions sought
and incorporated
the length of training sessions being
determined by the need
and nature of the training with
appropriate breaks
to facilitate concentration
post calls questionnaires simplified and
anonymized
induction training training for staff
that are requested to provide
training to members it's a mouth for
that one
alteration to the development training
to accommodate the differing needs
between new and experienced members
increased use of lga trainers and
changing trainers to encourage
greater attendance and addressing the
concerns over code of conduct training
by splitting parish and district
sessions
that's not a fully inclusive list but it
shows
the wealth of activity that the
member learning and development group
working group
undertook as can be expected from a
group comprised of members
from each political group there have
been some robust discussions and some
funny moments
such as when we found a member of staff
have decided to join our group
sorry has
decided to join our group to promote an
item they felt
members should consider without any
product communication or request to
attend
it is unusual for working groups to
suddenly find an uninvited
stranger in their midst the coronavirus
pandemic has necessitated some
alterations to the planned training
due to staff difficulty and courses have
been delivered by
soon the effectiveness of this i'm sure
will be accessed
assessed in due course the two areas of
difficulty that remained are the
concerns over chairmanship which i'm
sure will be addressed in future
and the problems created by the
licensing and appeals training
the report circulating was achieved
after very lengthy and robust debate
and seeks to address the concerns raised
in relation to licensing and appeals
particularly those of perceived
inequality
of treatment of members in my view the
strength and success of this working
group was due to the benefit of all
political groups
having equal representation thus
ensuring a balance in an
area that affects all members equally
i regret that this committee has decided
to alter that
tonight i will now take any questions
from the report
however i would like to make some small
amendments to the recommendations at the
end
in light of the changing circumstances
so if the chairman will bear with me
i'll take any questions that members
have and then return to the
recommendations
thank you councillor mrs mason um
councillor mrs gooding i believe you've
got a question
well can i just ask for some
clarification it's
on uh um item
seven uh page seven point two
uh recommendation two please
um what happens if a member doesn't
attend
both training sessions by the end of
september
in that municipal year
i i can clarify that that was one of the
alterations that we were
uh i was going to propose ordering we
would change must
um we cannot it's not a it's not a
requirement that members of the
committee have to attend training
centers
what we're trying to do is to encourage
and
to reinforce the importance so my my
that counselor mrs gooding was one of
the areas that i wanted to all to wear
to read that members of the licensing
and appeals committee
should rather than must there's nothing
we can do
if members don't wish to attend training
thank you um council mr septo you've got
a
question
thank you chairman um my question really
is with regards to the recommendations
now
it will be relevant to any alterations
that
uh councillor
[Music]
is um to propose so i'd like to hold my
questions back until she's had
a chance to give those uh um amendments
to the
recommendations because it may not be
relevant
thank you councillor steptoe has anybody
else any questions
uh councilman scooting did you want to
come back on something
yeah obviously it is subject to what
council mrs mason um
is proposing but if if they're only
encouraged to attend these training
um if you've not attended any training
would you actually be eligible to be on
a committee
if you've had no training for it yeah um
if i can clarify this when i say mrs
gooding
the training is not for the committee
the committee is a policy committee
and i'm sure angela and i will confirm
this because we have had
lengthy debates in the working group and
with various reports but the committee
you do not require training to sit on
the committee
you require training to seek one of the
appeals and the licensing appeals
and that's where the conundrum comes in
we explored lots of active
um alternatives such as allowing all
councillors to train so that we had a
bigger pool that apparently
would not be legally compliant the
members have to be drawn from that
committee
but because of the nature of the
committee you can't compel members to
track
um does that clarify that for you enough
council mrs budding or do you want
further
clarification sorry it was just the fact
that
it is the appeals and licensing
committee i was referring to
that's the way yes i know it is and the
appeals and licensing committee you do
not need
training to sit on it you need training
to sit on the appeals
hearings and the licensing hearings
and perhaps i'm not clarity explaining
this well enough
perhaps i could ask legal officer angela
law to clarify that for you
yes i think angela would like to do that
there
yes thank you chairman so for
clarification um
there are the members are members of the
licensing and appeals committee
if members do not attend training it
does not
mean they're disqualified as members of
the licensing
and appeals committee itself however if
members have not attended the
appropriate training
i i would be i would not be able to give
assurance
on that for that member to say that they
have the appropriate training to deal
with any
appeals or reviews coming up with
regards to
say a taxi license a premises license
and so forth
and given that these lice uh the
decisions of the appeals
um could go to a magistrates court then
it would not
like i said i would not be able to give
assurance that that our members have had
the appropriate training and information
to
make make such um robust decisions as
needed
um to stand up to challenge
thank you um i i've got some um
questions if that's okay or else and
some comments
um recommendation one um
i don't see any uh problem in the atl
as part of the working group we agree
that it brings expertise to the council
that can be shared
um now uh councillor mrs mason
you may already have preempted this
but um i've been speaking with
our licensing officer this was due to
the fact
that in recommendation two
we were offering further
training one-to-one basis
now this working group produced this
pre-covered
so i took it on myself to make sure that
that offer was still
possible unfortunately at this current
time
our licensing officer who provided the
training
does not have the capacity so we
um i will wait to hear your amendments
to that
and recommendation number three
i'm afraid i cannot support in any form
uh joined the working group i did air my
concerns
that we were stepping into the realm of
operational matters that should be left
to officers
i did ask if there was any
report or anything from our officer
and i was told at the working group
that it had been a conversation and
the officers were happy with this now
i then um asked if there what had been
anything passed over and i had a paper
now this process
works well as it is
and my view is we should leave that to
officers so um i would um
i will wait for your amendments
councillor mrs mason
but item three i will not be supporting
thank you
uh if there's any more questions i
please counsel mrs
lamley you've got some questions
thank you chairman it was more of a
comment than a question in relation to
membership
of the licensing and appeals committees
that we have to be absolutely certain
that they're sufficient
members on those committees that are
prepared to undertake the respective
necessary training
to be able to be available for choosing
from a pool of members who can at short
notice
be ready for an appeal
that was all thank you
counselor mr newport
hey chairman i i think um councillor
steptoe had his hand raised before but
if he's okay for me to proceed yeah okay
um yeah there's a couple of things um
that i just wanted to pick up on
um the monitoring officer said about she
wouldn't be confident
um of anyone sitting on a hearing if
they hadn't been trained but is that is
the train in a statutory requirement
or is it just a requirement of
the monitoring officer or the council in
terms of
you know making sure that you know we've
dotted the eyes and crossed the t's
in case it does go to court or appeal
and that has been my first question and
i'll just pick up on a point um you made
yourself
um chairman and i think it was about the
one-to-one training um and you said that
they
um they didn't have the capacity
am i writing that's what you said didn't
you about the one-to-one training
yeah you are correct counselor newport
and my suggestion but i'm awaiting um
council mrs mason's rewording would be
that that we work with other councils
for
members who miss our training to be able
to access them
you know i was just coming back to that
one-to-one training and the capacity
issue because
it kind of um i've asked repeatedly
about resourcing at the council and i've
been assured
by the managing director that there is
no issue with
um resourcing and so i wonder why
we're now finding that there is a
resourcing issue um for training that
is as we've already heard from the
monitoring officer
a really important matter to make sure
that members
are trained and that we can offer
uh that training to councillors who
maybe cannot attend
um training sessions um
councillor mr newport um the suggestion
will be to work closely with
other councils so members would be able
to access training
um did the monitoring officer want to
come back on anything that councilman
newport asked
yes chairman with regards to training as
i mentioned is
it is not a statutory requirement
however if a decision was to end up in
an appeal situation in the magistrates
court or the county
and i was and the judge had asked are
your men with sufficiency
sufficiently trained and those members
who made that decision hadn't um been
trained or or attended training then we
couldn't give that assurance
um and and that would put your the
decision into uh jeopardy
um when i'm asked by our auditors to
give assurance around training not just
for members but also officers um
you know are you is the training up to
date i
if members do not attend i could not
give assurance to the auditors that
members are up to date on their training
with regards to the capacity issue
chairman if i just may add
we are in an unusual situation this year
in that there's obviously we're still in
the middle of pandemic
legislation continues to change and the
the
uh pressure on our enforcement officers
not just this licensing team but other
enforcement officers due to the rapidly
changing legislation
has put extra pressure on them and
therefore
there is a capacity issue this year
however this may not be the case next
year
uh training will be given to members um
it just won't be given internally for
the time being we will we will source
external and other training methods for
members
thank you um uh councillor mr steptoe
yes thank you chairman um i'm gonna
raise a number of points on
on all the recommendations um first of
all recommendation one i don't have a
problem with the basis of the
recommendation
but i do think it needs to be a little
bit more clarified
uh on two on two points one
is the um allocation of the funding
um on a training or conference
amendment to go on has to have the
agreement of all of the
um group leaders
i know from experience that um
on occasions that has been refused one
group
member leader has uh refused
um for attending
there's no obligation for them to give a
reason
as to why that should be so i would like
to see there
that there is a and i was going to say
selection of
reasons why they can't go rather than
perhaps they just don't like that
particular member and
doesn't want them to go on it um i feel
that that needs to be
bolstered a little bit and to to clarify
that particular point
the second uh paragraph after that is
that
following the conference of course uh to
give a
written or verbal report to the rest of
the council again i know from experience
that that's not always necessarily
possible
um so again i'd like to see some some
clarification
uh with regards to that
and uh that needs to be
strengthened there a little bit
with regards to recommendation too
um the the training issue
um again i'm speaking from experience uh
having been on the licensing committee
before
where we've had a very serious um
licensing issue there are some members
that will remember the one i'm talking
about where we have to actually have
a reserve of members to serve
on the uh bills committee or the
licensing committee but
if they suddenly dropped out because it
was so complicated
now i believe that the panel is usually
made up of three members
if you need to have people in reserve
that's another three
so i i personally think that all members
of the licensing committee
should have the appeals and licensing
training
so again i feel that and picking up on
your point on item number three
i wouldn't disagree with you in saying
that
that is an operational matter and not
necessarily a policy matter
or there's one other point just going
back to the um
the training with regards to having
training from
outside councils i'm assuming that the
the basis of the training will be very
similar to
uh any training that we give but is
there any parts of that training
that are policy specific if that is the
case
then that may be a slight issue uh
for the trump for the trainers if
there's been given by
other accountants
thank you uh councillor steptoe um
uh just before i pass back to council
mrs
mason there are a couple more questions
but one thing that i would like to
um have considered in your amendments to
council mrs mason
is um on page 7.1
um at paragraph 2.1 of the report on
page 7.1 of the report there is a
recommendation
that in respect of non-mandatory
training there are two sessions of
training that are offered
and fewer than 25 of members
including parish town council
representatives
are booked to attend offices consider
amalgamating the two and running just
the session
that has the greatest number of members
booked to attend
effective members would therefore be
advisers only
one session would run um i completely
understand the sentiment behind this
but i think we have a problem in the
fact that sometimes
um councillors change more frequently
through parish councils
um so i wonder if we could change that
to a number
um instead that it would read that in
respect of non-mandatory training
where two sessions of training are
offered and fewer than
10 members included in parish town
council representatives
so if we could change that percentage to
a number um
that would be my suggestion council mrs
mason
um council mrs gooding you've got a
question
thank you chair i would just like to um
endorse what councillor steptoe has uh
has mentioned
and obviously falling in line with uh
angela law's uh recommendation that we
we should have the training in order to
be
on the licensing and appeals and that
really should be then
made mandatory if you're going to be a
member you'd only be a sitting member
that couldn't be chosen because
um that there wouldn't be the uh
the backing to know that you've had the
training
so i would agree with cancer steptoe on
that point
um i see no other hands up
or raised at the present is there any
other questions anybody before i hang
back to council mrs mason
no cancer mrs mason would like to come
back
you get my mouse in the right place um
well i thought we'd had all this out at
the meeting but there we go
let's start and go over it again
um some of those comments i quite agree
with some of some of
uh role so can we just take
the recommendations as they are and see
if we can get a consensus one at a time
because
obviously it's going to be difficult so
if
i deal with the first recommendation 2.1
um i certainly have got no objection to
that being changed to 10
and i don't think anyone else would
however that is the
existing policy this is not our policy
that was
made for the working group if um the
chairman will recall i think she was at
the last meeting
um that was something that we just put
in there as to remind
people we haven't altered it we haven't
changed it
it is the policy of the council at
present but as i said i've got no
objection to 2.1 to be
altered the only um
automation i would make and i would
propose is at the moment
it says a book to attend officers should
consider amalgamating the two
and running just for one session i think
we should
change that slightly to officers should
take all steps to amalgamate
it may not be possible obviously if
we've committed to outside
um in outside trainers but the reason
behind this was a cost
one and there have been sessions where
they've been two or three people
which is obviously very time consuming
and costly in both
council office of time and of course or
if we have to engage again
but again no objection so subject to the
10
10 members and officers should take all
steps to amalgamate then i'm
quite happy if that accommodates your uh
i will gladly um second that council mrs
mason i'm glad we both saw
a couple of points there to rectify
okay can you put that onto the phone and
get that one away so that we don't
quit get confused is that amanda or do
you want to take more
at the end um i think let's take them
all
at the end if that's okay um as sonja
you're keeping a record of these
amendments
right the recommendations that uh
council again that is
not um changing it that is the existing
council policy that hasn't changed um
i i think i can only speak there's a
group leader who has been approached and
i've been approached
to fund things which could be easily
funded by
um hatted councillors from the county
council and there really been county
council issues
so in that case we would say no the
funding should come from another council
but that aside i think um
there is a point there one of the things
i wanted to change
is that they should receive feedback i
feel these courses are very expensive if
you're talking hundreds of pounds um
they should there should be feedback
given
and we said either written on furball
we're not suggesting that
um it's a big report
but it can be done in the members time
they can send an email to everyone
they can um have a meeting and
do it that way we put both in to allow
for people that wouldn't want to give a
written report and i think it should
actually be
timed within three months of attending
so that the
the benefit of those courses that those
individuals go on
benefits the whole council um
it's a substantial amount 1500 pounds
it's i don't believe it's ever actually
been used
to its total um i set council steptoe's
point subject to the agreement of all
group leaders and i
perhaps that ought to be a change the
agreement of the majority
i'd be quite happy to but again this is
not
a recommendation this was a reiteration
of the policy of the council but i i
have no objection to that being altered
there should that satisfy council
sector's concerns yeah can i come back
on that
yeah yeah yes of course
fearsome is that okay to come back on
that yes it is thank you very much
councillor steptoe
i still think that uh i pick up on the
point that councillor mason mrs mason's
uh
uh comment about it being a majority of
the group members that would make
the situation a little easier but i do
feel that there should be
specific reasons uh she commented on
there the fact that uh
it was um she quoted a case where it
could have possibly been a county member
that was not the one i had particularly
in mind
uh the particular member at the time
still is not was not a member of another
council
that would have been benefit from this
i do feel that there should be specific
reasons
why a group leader can refuse the
um situation so i think that needs to be
worked out i would like to give the
reasons that he considers
um acceptable to him
and see if everyone agrees i again i
have no objection to there being
um a selection of reasons but
what i would i would i don't know
pardon me okay if i can come back on
that i'm traveling
so i can't i can't give freezers off the
top of my head
for something that we're we this is an
existing council policy
so it would be wrong with me to try and
to formulate reasons now
but as councillor steptoes obviously
thought this through perhaps he would be
able to give us some
yes certainly i think i think it should
be on the on on the basis of
uh what the benefit is to the uh the
council itself
um if the group leader was for example
not
just it was a benefit for for the
council
to give their reasons why that was not a
benefit
and if for example um a member has
uh the opportunity to have going on a
course where they're perhaps a member of
a group that can get a discount on that
again i think the group leaders ought to
take that into account
they're the two that i can give off the
top of my head but i think
in essence that if a group leader has a
problem with somebody going on a
particular course
that that should necess that should be
parted to the monitoring officer
rather than not necessarily to the
member back to the monitoring officer to
make sure
it's a it is a valid reason
yeah did you cancel would you like that
changed uh that suggestion changed to a
majority of group leaders
rather than all great leaders yes i i
would i would be happier with that i
think that would be more
could we please for the benefit of our
officers just clarify that amendment
please
uh council mrs mason right
tell us correct me if i go wrong um so
that the current arrangements for
funding attendance for individual
members of the council at external
training
or conference be confirmed and you see
they were they were nothing that we
altered
with the addition of the requirement for
the member to provide
feedback either written or verbal within
three months of attending to the rest of
the council
and then as follows that an amount of
1500
be identified each year out of the
member training budget for individual
members to be able to request
attendance at external conferences
training policies
the allocation of such training to be
subject to the agreement
of a majority of group leaders
and reasons for refusal or acceptance
because it's the same isn't it refusal
or acceptance um
would be benefit to the council um
or economic reasons i think we'll say
rather than
we're getting i think it's a bit
discriminatory actually because a member
gets a discount but obviously oh
perhaps economic benefit to the council
family i'd be happy to accept that as an
amendment
thank you then
the other sentence again that following
the conference called that the member
will be required to give feedback
written available to the rest of the
council within three months of attending
that's a repeat
but repeat it
are you happy with that
yes i'll accept that good i mean there
was no intention of changing it that
if we can improve things let's use
though
agreed thank you very much um
council mrs mason do you want to move on
to the next recommendation
right the singing of an appeals now this
obviously
has been a contentious subject over the
time
and there's quite a few issues here that
have come up that seems to be we can't
make
something mandatory just because someone
suggests it so
the situation is that the committee
training is not mandatory
and we have to encourage
that so i would the one word that i had
already put in there that i wanted
would like the committee to consider
changing
is where it reads a further course or
one-to-one training both subjects to be
offered
as needed well in the lightest um
of what's being said as needed if
possible
and with the um approval of the chairman
of the committee
uh is fine and i've got no objection to
it being sourced from outside
um attending other councils but i don't
know how practical that would be
bearing in mind monitoring officers just
said that
you know we should be back to normal
hopefully next year
we the internal training the members the
the majority of the members
obviously felt that the internal trainer
was very good i'm not saying that
personally i felt that the trainer that
we had
externally was also very good so um
this year that is so um
i'm not quite sure how you want that
altered um
we may i want one training
as as possible as as possible
and approved by the chair of standards
if that accepts is acceptable to
councilman pearson
um well actually accounts mrs mason i've
been um drafting something because then
we were
working through the papers um
i i was thinking of the wording of a
further course
or one-to-one training on both subjects
to be offered
if officer capacity permits or
externally resourced wised mindful
of our taxi conditions
because our conditions with our taxi
licensing
do differ slightly from local authority
to local authority
um
yes the only thing i would like to alter
is that where we
put and we put must in i must admit we
did it with a bit of cheek because we
knew that
it wasn't compulsory it's um
members of the licensing and appeals
committee should attend at least one
training session
but are encouraged to attend both
we cannot compel and
the reasons for that
i will go into summary that the reasons
there have been difficulties i mean
an officer produced a phone me up agreed
to reduce
or wanted to give a report that gave us
actually
a different thing to what we agreed over
the phone
which is the document that council and
mrs mcpherson is referring to
which i have incorporated as far as i
can
but the reason that there are
difficulties
with members training for licensing and
appeals
is because members have taken the
training
and there haven't been used because the
method of using or
contacting members that are trained
has been such that it's disadvantaged
members that aren't sitting at the end
of the phone
that means they're discouraged that
means they don't get training
and there's lots of other reasons i mean
it's perceived by some members as a
political bias
i'm not saying that it is it's certainly
perceived as discriminatory and again
i'm not saying that it is but some
people are concerned about that
that is the reason why the procedure was
put in
but so to go it was trying to make a
bigger pull
of members that are trained to assist
the officers
in uh getting members to serve on the
committee
so certainly with the change that
councilman pearson's put and if we can
change the master should
are you happy with that council mrs
mcpherson
i'm sorry um uh councillor mrs mason are
you still talking on recommendation two
or have you moved on to three
yes um recommendation two i'm fine with
yes
um it's recommendation three that i
would like removed
right recommendation three came about
because of the problems that were
created by the officers the procedure
that the officers were using
what we have done in the committee if we
have kept as far as possible
to the um procedure that the office has
used we shouldn't have to do this
but we have had to do it because of the
way that
um members were requested
or not requested to attend appealing
appeal hearings
so there's no even if you insist that
members
are trained you can't compel them to
attend the appeals so we want to make it
as attractive as possible and as fair as
possible
and the whole of this item this
procedure which was agreed
at the end of a very lengthy discussion
which i'm sure
um the members will recall
was to ensure fairness and
inclusivity because what otherwise we
will go back to the situation that we've
had and i think was
serious last year where an officer had
difficulty in finding people to
go onto an appeals here as i understand
it
because people weren't available and
people weren't available because members
didn't want to do the training because
members don't want to be trained
when that training is not going to be
utilized
so i i do think that's an important part
of the recommendations
and i'm not happy to withdraw it's a
recommendation from the whole group the
only recommendation that i would like to
add and this is again to facilitate this
you must remember that training is for
the benefit of
and we are asking members to give up
their time
a lot of our members work so i would
like to
also put another recommendation in that
we request that consideration is given
to the licensing and appeals
committees to be held in the evenings
so that members serving on those
committees can use the spare daytime
hours that their employers
may allow them for him
there are some members that will be able
to take perhaps one or two daytime
sessions off from hearing but if they've
utilized that
their employer's generosity
to attend meetings then that
diminishes all of people available
for the hearings and the whole
point of that procedure
is to encourage a greater participation
and to facilitate member involvement
first of all um our monitoring officer
would like to come back on a few things
i believe
thank you very much um training is
important training
um for members will actually extend the
pool
of um members that we can um
pick from when it comes to a situation
where we do have to
run a review or
a hearing at short notice
i don't agree with council and mrs
mason's um
comments around that the procedure not
working previously i do think it has
worked
it's just the nature of the legislation
as to how it's been
uh drafted uh we simply can't um
if we had a a review hearing that has to
be held within five working days
to make the first call and then wait
until the next day for an answer at 10
a.m
that what that first day of the five
working days is already gone
um and then if that member is not
available then we have to
make the second quarter wait for this
the next
procedures excuse me
mason councillor mrs mason can we please
let the monitoring officer finish
except it's not a procedure
uh councillor mrs mason could we please
let the monetary officer finish
thank you so sorry so i am speaking to i
know
it's it's i'm speaking to number three
at the moment sorry
um so our previous um
procedures do work and they continue to
work um
in response to um council mrs mason's
amendment to say they
uh that the members of the licensing
appeals
should attend at least one i i'm
from office's point of view i do not um
advise
agreement to that but um it's as i said
the more members we can have trained the
more the more um
choice we can have when it comes to um
selecting for
any review hearings any appeal hearings
especially if say
you know we have a serious incident
within our district with regards to any
of the licenses we do need to be able to
get that
hearing up and running as soon as
possible i just want to make one more
comment about um
evening appeal hearings
um the license and appeals committee the
appeals
um members they are acting in a
quasi-judicial
um manner and um some and
some licensees will have
legal representatives attending with
them um
it wouldn't be practical for us to
suggest that
the hearings um happen in the evening
um because maybe their license their
their legal representative may not be
able to attend we
the courts don't offer evening um appeal
hearings or any
hearings in the evening so we need to
also take into consideration the
livelihoods of those
um licensees whose um licenses are at
risk
of being revoked or suspended
counsellor mike stepped mr setto
i'm afraid i did have my hand up for for
a comment on
uh item recommendation two there uh in
the brackets
um there was a comment that we can't
make it mandatory
i believe that we can uh because
planning is tr uh mandatory which is uh
quite
i'm trying to quote the legal officer
quasi
legal um situation where
you are acting in a legal capacity
and i do feel that the training if we've
got um
members on that particular committee or
that particular panel
that is not properly trained we are
going to leave ourselves wide open
for uh appeal against us and obviously
the cost
of doing that so i have a concern with
that
uh with regards to item 3
i don't see the relevance of item 3 at
all the system was working quite well
before
as the monitoring officer has already
said to hold meetings
in the evening would not be practical
because of the legal
um uh representation that a person may
wish to have
so we've got to take that in into
account as well
so i can't support either of those two
recommendations as they currently stand
councillor mrs mason yeah as a from the
border
the monitoring officer has misunderstood
and misrepresented
two of the statements i made firstly
i did not suggest the appeals were held
in the evenings
i understand the complexities and the
difficulties that
i suggested the licensing and appeals
committee was held in the evenings i
have got
i i'm well aware that other people
attend and wouldn't be able to
uh tell you the evening so that's a
misleading statement
thank you for clarifying that
if you let me finish the procedure again
of the telephone call does not take five
days if you look at item 10
the example those calls i
don't know that we could have made it
much clearer those calls are all made at
the same time and the first
day so the officer makes a first call a
second call a third caller for
consecutive calls until they get the
number of people they want
and by 10 o'clock the next day they will
have their committee confirmed
so that is not delaying at all it is
however keeping members acquainted
in the past and this has been um
verbalized
by members in committee and they've told
it were examples where members have
trained for over two years and not been
asked once
we have had members that have come off
of the committee
because their training wasn't utilized
we have had
um we're told that we by the officers
that they phone the first people they
know
available that is not democratic and
perhaps we don't want a democratic
committee i
would i will interject there please
counselor
uh mrs mason um as you
rightly said you've highlighted the
issue
in the past the officer has been aware
of the issues that you've raised before
um the officer has addressed that in
finding members for the panel it is an
operational
matter this and i do not think um
recommendation three should be on the
table i'm afraid uh
councillor mrs goodin
i totally agree with with you uh
councilman mcpherson
and i would further support what um
councillor steptoe has suggested that
the mandatory training in order for the
uh
the monitor in the officer to have
confidence
in the members to be on the panel
to be trained would be my preferred
recommendation
thank you uh councillor mr newport
you chairman i'm just going back to this
um procedure and
uh the comments about this being an
operational matter
i actually don't find it um i
i i actually don't find um
that we shouldn't be um helping officers
if um
we we think that operational matters can
be tweaked
um and made better because i've spoken
to many an officer and
made suggestions about operational
matters um i've spoken to
portfolio holders about operational
matters could be made better and they've
all been
willing to listen and and to adopt some
of those
um operational matters and i think that
um
in in an example myself if i was on on
on a member that was trained um
and being phoned up to be on one of
those um
panels that maybe i couldn't answer my
phone if i was at work
so you know it seems like a bit of a at
the moment
some in some respects a bit of a panic
situation where it shouldn't and more
opportunities should be given to those
of us
that are trained and wish to go on the
panel
and i think this i think this procedure
this operational procedure could be
tweaked and
make it more um inclusive for other
members
that that perhaps are at work and
they're unable to answer their phone
straight away
um you know and you know as long as they
get back to
um the officer i don't really see any
any
reasons why we should object
um accounts for newport i can only speak
from personal experience
um having sat on licenses in the
materials for some years
i've received calls i've received
messages
and i have called the officer back and
taken up that opportunity
some of this is quite historical now and
the officer has readdressed some of the
operations
their self to make sure that it is more
inclusive
for everyone um counsellor mr scepter
you want to come back
yes uh chairman thank you um i'd like to
uh um make two proposals if i may
now firstly with uh um the
um
um 2.2 item two
that we make that uh a mandatory uh
situation uh that i feel gives the
confidence to the offer
and the legal side of things to make
sure that that is the case
um sorry to interrupt your counselor
could i just
confirm with the monitoring officer that
that is possible
chairman i believe um counselor mrs
mason had made a motion to
amend um the recommendations so we need
to
um make we are having a debate on those
we need to vote on those
if that if that motion fails then
perhaps councillor steptoe may be able
to put forward his recommendations for
amendment
thank you um so um
cancer mr secretary did you want to say
anything more on that
because we will go back to these nations
yes
i'll hold back on the uh proposals uh
under the guidance of the officer there
but i was going to say on the item 2.23
picking up on council newport's a point
there
that it would be perhaps suggested
method for officers to
adopt rather than for the status
committee to impose
okay there's some food for thought um
i can see no more hands raised
so um i think we need to take these
recommendations one at a time
unless the officers want to tell me
otherwise and
if we can return to you please counsel
mrs mason
to take these individually
all right so if we go right back to
oh dear where were we um 2-1
i think um sonya has the wording for
that one doesn't she
so um should you want me to read it
through again
or has the officer got that
i've got it for uh for paragraph 2.1
yeah it was to change the 25 to 10
should take all steps to amalgamate
around just one session so perhaps you'd
like to review
so that everyone's clearing what they're
voting certainly
so the current arrangements for minimum
attendance
at training sessions uh excluding
planning licensing appeals training be
confirmed as
follows that in respect of non-mandatory
training
where two sessions of training are
offered and fewer than 10
of 10 members including parish town
council
representatives are booked to attend
officers
should take all steps to amalgamate
the two and running just the session
that has a greater number of members
booked to attend
effective members to be advised that
only one session would be run
chairman i understand chairman
understand you were the seconder for
that i am yes thank you
so i've second that and sonia can we go
to a vote on that
of course so um same as before please uh
members
if um when i call your name if you could
indicate you want a recorded vote and
then whether you want to vote for
or against or abstain so councillor
mrs carter thank you
recorded vote and uh for
thank you uh councillor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and four thank you
councillor lucas girl no recorded vote
and four council mrs lovely
no and four councillor mrs mcpherson
no recorded vote and four counsellor
newport
hello unfortunately counselor
oh and against
and counselor wilson no
and four thank you uh
so that's um that's uh no recorded vote
and
seven uh four and one against
thank you um council mrs um mason if we
can go back to you
for um the first recommendation under
2.2
okay the um
the current arrangements for funding
attendance individual members of the
council at external training
or congress
for the member to provide feedback
either written or verbal within three
months of attending
the rest of the council and
the confirmation is this the an amount
of up to 1500 being
identified each year after the member
training budget
for individual members to be able to
request attendance that is
still an advantage in courses the
such training to be subject to the
agreement of the majority of group
leaders
the reason for refusal or or acceptance
would be the benefit to the discount of
financial
considerations i think that's
basically what council stepped and i
agree does that correct cancer september
and that's it and secondary please
i'm happy to second that chair thank you
councillor steptoe
so um counselor mrs carter
thank you no recorded vote and agree
council mrs bidding no recorded vote
and agreed
answered no and
agreed cancer mrs lemley
no and four
council mrs mcpherson no and four
councillor newport no one for
cancer two no and four
cancer wilson no and four
it's unanimous chairman thank you very
much
um council mrs mason uh the second
recommendation 2.2 i think this is the
one that
um we altered to your requirements
ladies and gentlemen and that you
flipping with it
i'll read it through and correct me if
i'm
not put it correct that licensing and
appeals committee training very similar
to that of development committee
training one course to be offered for
licensing training
daytime and evening one course to be
offered for taxi office training
daytime and evening the further calls
course one-to-one training on both
subjects to be offered
as capacity permits or external
courses are available if they are
suitable
because of what are the courses to be
determined
by the challenge standards committee and
chairman of the working group
members of the licensing initiative
committee should attend at least one
training session
um but they're encouraged to attend both
each
of the year preferably by the end of
september
in that really simple year so
that's what we agreed on i don't know i
think people actually wanted it
again but i'm happy to listen to any
suggestions
thank you um i will second that
amendment
chair i didn't hear the last part of
what council of masons mason there
said can you i think it is
yes certainly counselors i said i think
you wanted it slightly altered
and i'm quite happy to accommodate that
with anything but i wasn't sure where
you wanted it altered
i think it was towards the end
my suggestion was that it should be
mandatory training
well that's not in the proposal so we've
got a proposal and a seconder
sonia could you put that to the vote
please yes so
cancer mrs carter thank you
thank you so i'm not sure can you hear
me yes yes
yes thank you yeah um yes i recorded
vote and agree
cancer mrs gooding no recorded vote and
against
councillor lucas gill no and
agreed answer mrs lumley
cancer mrs lumley
so you're on mute and there we go oh
sorry
no and against
cancer mrs mcpherson no and four
wransler newport no
and four councillor steptoe
oh and against cancer wilson
no and four
so there's no recorded vote and five
voted
for and three against
thank you um
and uh council mrs mason
um have uh you've got um a third
recommendation
third one was the proposed procedure
which seems to have been
the most controversial but it was one
that was aiming to be the most
inclusive um i
think someone suggested that we make
this a suggestion
or um an outline or a guideline i'm
quite happy to go along with that we
didn't want to over prescribe
what we didn't want is to disillusion
members that have done the training
so i'm quite happy to change that to um
a suggested guideline for the officers
if that wasn't german could i just add a
little bit to that
if possible yeah yes you can counsellor
steptoe
yes a suggestive guideline where
practical
because mrs mason are you happy with
that wording
yes i can't see what's
the the issue seems to be allowing
expecting a member to be on the end of
the phone at that minute that that
officer's
officer
phones and i i as long as there's some
time lag
i mean we put 10 o'clock in because it
was the next day because someone come
home from work and leave a message
but um so we were trying to be as
practical as possible but i don't mind
that what i wouldn't want
is for the system that happened before
yeah um cancer mrs mason could we just
have your um recommendation
um put forward as you would like hitler
please
um a proposed guard like as
as far as possible perhaps
i think it was where practical that uh
councillor steptoe just suggested
yes this correct yeah well i think it is
practical
generally speaking i i i am concerned if
we just say we're practical someone's
like
it's not practical so i think the
objective should
try to um use it as an outline
rather than um not
but having said i i've got no strong
feelings because when it comes down to
it that the
people that will suffer at the end of
this will be
the council itself if you think
franchises members by
disillusioning them and not then they
won't be
ending appeals i i think absolutely
mason i'm going to um press you a little
bit could we have your revised
recommendation please
yes i proposed a procedure proposed
guidelines
how would that would that suit i'm happy
to take that
so um i'll change it to proposed
guidelines for the organisation of
pharisees licensing hearing
okay sonia would you like to um read
that out would you like me to read it
out and um
i can be corrected if you would like um
that the proposed guidelines
for the organization premises licensing
hearing and taxi
licensee appeals uh be attached as to
this report
chairman if i may um i'm just reading
the recommendation in full if you read
it
from 2.2 it is further proposed by the
working group that the committee
recommends to council that the proposed
guidelines you're almost
without being pedantic it sounds like
you're proposing guidelines for
council to adopt if that makes sense
yeah i'm sorry i was repeating uh
councillor mrs mason
yeah i i don't know i appreciate i think
i i just think the wording may need a
bit of tweaking
taking into account the uh first few
words of the um
uh the recommendations so if we read it
to say it is further proposed by the
working group
that the committee recommends to council
that the proposed guideline
to without being like i said without
being pedantic
it it sounds like you are proposing
those guidelines to council and for them
to accept that
rather than um making it as a
suggestion for officers to follow
i would like to thank the assistant
director yes i think that's a very
helpful alteration
so counselling mrs mason just for
clarity could you please read out that
third recommendation i haven't noticed
that dale so perhaps angela could do
that for you
so i would suggest um let me think
sorry
it is further proposed by the working
group that the committee recommends to
council
the suggested guidelines
for the organization of premises
licensing hearings and taxi licensing
appeals be as attached to this report
are you happy with that council mrs
mason yes yes
thank you lovely have we a seconder
yeah i'll i'll second that um
who was that please on the airport
thank you
so uh sonia would you take it to the
vote please
so counselor mrs carter thank you
no recorded vote and four councillor mrs
gooding
no recorded vote and against
councillor lucas gill no and four
thanks to mrs lumley no
and four hands and mrs mcpherson
no and against
cancer newport no and four
could you um note my vote in the minutes
please
cancel no and against
and cancel wilson no and
four so that's uh that's
five four and three against
thank you very much um
uh sorry could you give us those figures
again please on you so we know
five four and three against okay
so that motion's removed um
that i believe concludes our agenda
sorry chairman apologies um i'm gonna
take the belt and braces approach here
so what just happened is that members
had
made amen amendments were made and
seconded and members had accepted all
those amendments
um perhaps um just for clarification can
we take
uh through you chairman if agreeable a
vote on
block for recommendation the new amended
recommendations
2.1 and 2.2 just so we can get a
final approval on the um new wording of
the um
the amen uh the recommendations as
agreed
so yeah what just happened was that we
agreed the amendments but we haven't
actually
agreed the recommendations yes
thank you if you can take us through
those chairman if i may
um yes i'm a little unclear there
uh because i if you're going to do all
of those
on block um i would have to vote against
them all
as a block vote because i'm not happy
with
some of the recommendations yeah
actually if we go back to the monitoring
officer
in that case
i voted against some of the
recommendations so chairman you would
need agreement that
um with the committee members that
they're happy to take it on block but um
you have council might step so who wants
uh who's not in agreement so you would
have to take those four recommendations
separately
so chairman you would need to vote on
the new recommendation 2.1
okay so let me just clarify this please
um this is because we have voted on
amendments
yes those amendments now stand as we
just have
now we are just voting for exactly the
same
but as a whole as no no you're voting
for the new
recommendations with the amendments in
so you agreed the amendments those
amendments are agreed
yeah and now it means that those
uh recommendations has been amended um
as per
um the votes so you're the the so 2.1
for example will read
uh that in respect of non-mandated
training where two sessions of the
training are offered and fewer than 10
members so you're voting for that new
recommendation
not the amendment the recommendation has
been amended
so perhaps if sonya could read out each
of the new recommendations
and we take a vote on each of those
you're not voting for the amendments
you're voting for the actual
recommendation now
right um okay i might need assistance on
that because um
i don't like to challenge them
monitoring officer
but if we have voted individually
on each amendment
i'm i'm a little bit lost why we're
having to do the process
again chairman those recommendations
have been changed
because amendments were put forward
proposed and seconded and
and and those amendments were accepted
so now you instead of
the recommendation that's on the paper
you have new
uh new recommendation that's slightly
amended
if all members had agreed we could have
taken or
both recommendations on block however as
councillor steptoe has said
he didn't necessarily agree with those
new recommendations so you will need
to um take each uh recommendation
separately okay so
cal says so i'm just using an example
counselor
uh did not agree with recommendation
one was a council stepped out and i
didn't agree with recommendation 2.2
but perhaps i can help the motor officer
here a little bit
uh the the the most the
recommendation has been amended on 2.1
and that now becomes the substantive
motion
and then recommendation 2.2
in each individual item
has been mended and each one of those
becomes a substantive motion
i think that's correct yes individually
yes yes right okay so i'm
sorry sonia it is on um three
uh the other thing that i just want to
clarify also
and uh if am i correct in thinking that
counselor mrs mason
also moved an additional you know uh
uh uh recommendation to
uh to the to the um uh paragraph 2.2
uh item four which was around the
scheduling of the um the full licensing
appeals committee in
evening you know in the evenings for
consideration to be given to that
and i don't think we actually voted on
uh on that sort of
you know additional um uh you know
amendment to the uh
to to to to to them to the motion at
paragraph two point
two if i can say mrs mason
if i can clarify madam chairman i didn't
put the motion but i didn't put it as an
amendment to 2.2 but it's an additional
motion
and basically that the uh
that the committee requests that
consideration be given to the licensing
and appeals committee
i don't believe that was seconded no it
hasn't been seconded as far as i'm aware
i don't know
okay right so
if we go to um if we go to
recommendation uh
2.1 um
so it's proposed by the working group
that the committee resolves that the
current arrangements for minimum
attended
training sessions excluding planning
licensing appeals training be confirmed
as follows
within respect of non-mandatory training
where two sessions of training are
offered and fewer
than 10 members including parish town
council representatives are booked to
attend
offices um where are we
too many bits of paper here
officers should take all steps to
amalgamate
the two sessions
and running just the session right
officers should take
all all steps to um amalgamate the two
sessions and run just the session that
has the greater number of members looked
to attend uh
effective members of advisor only one
session was run
um so we can sort of take a vote on that
one please first of all on that
substantive motion
as amended counsellor mrs
carter
thank you no recorded vote and four
thank you councillor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and four thank you
councillor lucas gill no and
four councillor mrs lumley
no and four
hands and mrs mcpherson um
counselor newport no one for
cancer steptoe
so that is seven four and one against
okay
so moving on to
2 2.2 and
recommendation one that the current
arrangements for funding attendance with
individual members of the council's
external training
or conference be confirmed uh with the
addition of the requirement
for the member to provide feedback
either written or verbal to the rest of
the council within three months of
attending
um that amount of up to 1500 be
identified each year
out of a member training budget for
individual members to be able to request
attendance
at external conferences training courses
the allocation of such training to be
subject to the agreement of the majority
of group leaders
um and that following the
conference and and subject to um
uh reasons provided uh in support of or
against uh that decision
based on um economic benefit to the
council
and that following uh that's repetition
i think so i think that's where it
ends um is that correct
so if i could ask members um
i'm sorry sonia that's not quite correct
it was the the reasons were
the refusal or acceptance were the
benefit to the council
and financial considerations okay
that's what we actually voted on so
atlantic but let's get it right the
benefit to benefit to the council
and financial considerations thank you
okay
so
in terms of the uh that that sort of
substantive motion
at uh 2.21 um
councillor mrs carter thank you
no recorded vote before
councillor mrs gooding no recorded vote
and four thank you councillor lucas gill
no and four announced to mrs lumley
no and four cancer mrs mcpherson
no and for cancer newport
no and for cancer steptoe
no and four cancer wilson
no and four okay that one's unanimous
so moving to recommendation
two
um that licensing and appeals
uh committee training be similar to that
of development committee training
one course should be offered for
licensing training daytime and evening
one course to be offered for taxi
appeals
training daytime and evening a further
course or one-to-one training on both
subjects to be
offered
if officer capacity permits
or externally resourced
okay
so details for the course is to be
determined by the chairman of standards
committee and chairman of the working
group members of the licensing appeals
committee
um should attend at least one training
session
but are occurs to attend both each
municipal year by the end of september
in that municipal year
so um sorry sonia madame chairman
murders come in we missed a couple of
words out it was
externally resourced if suitable
with so
uh externally sourced if suitable
thank you follow your interaction
that's fine so um
counselor mrs carter
thank you no recorded vote number four
answer mrs gooding no recorded vote and
against thank you
can answer lucas girl no and four
counts to mrs lumley no and against
that's where mrs mcpherson no
and before council newport
no and four please council stepton
no and against
cancer wilson no and four
so that's um five voting for
uh this substantive motion and three
against
then moving on to the last
recommendation set out in the report um
the stamps of motion i believe
was that um that the the guidelines
for the organization of premises
licensing hearings and taxi licensing
appeals to be as attached to the report
i believe it was the suggested
guidelines for the organization chairman
thank you um uh would that monitor an
officer would like to clarify that a
whole
um recommendation to make it easy it
um i think it was agreed that the
wording would be uh
the suggested guidelines for the
organization or the premises
licensing hearings and taxi licensing
appeals be attached to this report
okay so um councillor mrs carter
thank you no recorded vote and four
cancer mrs gooding no recorded vote
and against cancer lucas girl
no and four counts to mrs lumley
no and for council mrs mcpherson
no and against
councillor newport no i'm for
and uh could you note my vote in the
minutes please
answer oh and against
councillor wilson no and four
so that's five votes for the substantive
motion and three
against
thank you i think that that does now
conclude this evening
and may i say thank you very much
everyone
and our officers and have a lovely rest
of the evening
thank you good night